[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend Gabriel
on commence avec un événement les nuits
de la lecture qui font son grand leur
grand retour oui avis aux grands
lecteurs ou aux amateurs la nuit de la
lecture les nuits de la lecture font
leur grand retour dans les médiathèques
du territoire organisé par le Centre
national du livre cette année l'édition
s'articule autour du thème du corps pour
faire écho bien sûr aux Jeux Olympiques
pour l'occasion des soirées spéciales
sont prévues dans plusieurs lieux
culturels au programme concert
littéraire conférence mais aussi atelier
débat tout ça autour de la lecture
Marion vaillant responsable de la
bibliothèque Albert Camu de
saint-irlécole nous parle de
[Musique]
l'événement tous les
ans le ministère de la Culture prévoit
les nuits de la lecture en bibliothèque
al il y a pas que les bibliothèques a
les librairies il y a a certains musées
les archives et c'est que c'est un
moment dédié à la lecture et surtout à
la lecture
publique la nuit de la lecture c'est un
moment aussi où on va combler les les
envies de certains lecteurs qui sont
très friants de de ce genre de
d'animation vraiment dans la localité de
proximité ce qui est pour nous très
important parce qu'on a une bibliothèque
de proximité
[Musique]
alors le vendredi on va faire une vraie
nuit parce qu'on va fermer à 22h on va
proposer une soirée jeux de société
parce que nous avons une ludothèque à la
bibliothèque et donc on va présenter des
petits jeux familiaux des petits jeux
aussi d'ambiance des nouveautés et le
samedi ce sera plus une journée
familiale aux horaires de d'habitude 10h
18h où là on va proposer alors des
rendez-vous comptes le matin 3 6 ans à
peu près et un atelier de d'écriture
autour du cheval parce que on a décidé
de travailler
[Musique]
l'équitation et à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline aussi vous avez des rendez-vous
qui sont proposés rendez-vous sur le
site
immediathek.sky.fr pour découvrir le
programme on poursuit vos idées de
sortie Gabriel avec une exposition
temporaire au musée Lambinet de
Versailles oui jusqu'au 25 février le
musée Lambinet rend hommage au peintre
Alexandre jeanubois draonet inconnu du
grand public le musée a pu mettre à
l'honneur les toiles de l'artiste grâce
à une soixantaine de près de musées
français et internationaux l'occasion
pour les visiteurs de découvrir les
œuvres de ce portraitiste dont les liens
avec Versailles sont important car c'est
dans la commune que le peintre a débuté
sa carrière en y installant son atelier
parmi ses œuvres de nombreux portraits
de militaires de personnalités
artistiques ou encore d'habitants des
œuvres qui regorgent de richesse et
d'information sur l'histoire de
Versailles un weekend placé sous le
signe de la culture mais aussi du sport
avec une course à ne pas louper oui à ne
pas louper je dirais même insolite ce
dimanche a lieu la 4e édition de la toar
morning r race aux EAU DE Toir plusieurs
départs de cours sont proposés toute la
matinée alors malheureusement Mathilde
pour vous les inscriptions sont closes
mais vous pouvez profiter du spectacle
en allant soutenir les coureurs tout ça
dans un cadre féérique puisque le TR de
la course passe au travers des
illuminations et du zoo de quoi
réchauffer un petit peu les visiteurs du
zoo ce weekend et pour ce réchauffer
Gabriel vous nous proposez également un
concert à carrière souspoissie oui et
pour cause la musique va raisonner
vendredi soir au château éphémère de
carrière souspoissie des 19h le château
accueillera concert DJ mais aussi
installation visuelle pour une soirée
festive parmi les artistes Axel Rigot on
écoute un
extrait
[Musique]
pour assister au concert rendez-vous sur
le site du château éphéè et à Guill en
cour le weekend sera aussi festif avec
les soirées studioos en scène qui font
leur retour oui et pour l'occasion la
batterie présente trois pépites
musicales pop rock sorti tout droit de
leur studio otage knock me out ou encore
gray and jbes le but de cette soirée
faire découvrir les artistes du
territoire et faire rencontrer les
musiciens et leur public bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel moi aussi j'ai une idée
de sortie à vous proposer